My Aunt Sally is on line two.
Aunt Sal, what up?
Hey, you did okay
the other night.
Yeah.
Just okay?
You did great, babe.
Thank you Aunt Sal.
Yeah, you did real good.
What was your favorite part,
any ...
The end of it.
The end of it?
Oh. You old bitch.
Good morning squirt nation.
It's You Up with Nikki Glaser.
This is Nikki Glaser.
I am in New York City because
I am no longer in Los Angeles
because I was voted off
Dancing With the Stars.
Two nights ago.
I can't even believe it was
just so like two nights ago.
It was so recent.
I'm in studio today
in New York City.
Tom Thakkar is not here today,
he is in Toronto
all weekend performing at the
Just for Laughs Festival,
but today to fill in
for him we've got
Puddle Boy Andrew Collin.
Puddle, puddle, squirt, squirt.
Mm-hmm (affirmative).
Yup. All right.
All right. And then, this show's
off to a great start.
I thought you were going to
come in with like a Tom song.
I'm never good at the beginning
or the end.
Okay.
In the middle, though,
I'm great.
Listen and that's what
anyone remembers
is the beginning and the end.
And that's why you're ...
A star.
Immemborable.
That's why I used
to walk your dogs.
For free.
For free?
Huh? You paid me?
Yes I did. Don't make it sound
like you ever walked my ...
I paid you well.
Do I owe you money still?
Is that what this is about?
I mean I didn't want to
do it on air, but ...
Do I owe you money still?
Just $50,000.
No way though.
No, you honestly, I counted,
it's three walks you still ...
I still owe you for three walks?
Are you serious?
Do I literally owe you
for three walks?
I will Venmo you right now.
Pay $60 please. I'll send it
right back because I'm lying.
Are you ... do I owe you?
No. What kind of monster
would I be?
But you do owe me
for carrying that bag
up the stairs last night.
I do, I do.
Andrew came over last night.
Ian Fidance is here by the way,
everyone. How's it going, Ian?
Hey. I loved you on Dancing
With the Stars.
Thank you.
Yeah, it was amazing and I was
wondering,
you were dancing so well
and the judges were terrible.
I thought one of them-
Yeah, it's like what is your
pressing question for me.
Well, I just thought
one of the judges,
they had all this time
to critique you
but none of them asked
how's your butt hole.
And you know what I had so much
to say about that.
Can we clear up all Dancing
With the Stars ...
can I just, I'll just say
Cheryl Burke
who's been on the show
since, for 21 seasons,
says they've never had to do
this much work on a show,
on the first two weeks
of a show.
We had to learn three dances,
usually you do one dance
a week in the beginning
and then it gets more intense.
This was I had to learn
four dances
but I never got to the fourth
but I learned three.
You'll see, I'll post videos
from my rehearsals
because I do some
pretty impressive stuff
in the third dance, I gotta say.
But I got injured from working
on the third dance,
which I never got to perform,
and then ...
so I was just, I was bummed man.
I was really sad and Gleb and I
weren't really getting along.
Not that I wasn't getting along,
but I was just so disappointed
in myself for him
because he's such a good dancer
and I want him to be on the show
and when your eliminated
you don't ...
he's still going to be featured
on the show but I was,
I just felt like such a failure
for him and he was mad
that I was injured
but not mad at me.
We just, it's such a weird
relationship with your dancer.
It's like a relationship
and I was like, I feel like Gleb
has filed for divorce
and hasn't told me yet.
Like that's kind of
the sense I got,
like he's already checked out
and then I eventually ...
we kind of connected
and had a good moment
before our first dance
where he was like,
"You got this,
believe in yourself."
And everything.
And I also got a couple emails
from people being like,
mind over matter,
we know you're injured.
This one friend wrote and email
that said she coaches gymnastics
and when her gymnasts
get injured
she tells them to repeat
the mantra,
"I'm strong, I'm prepared,
and this is easy."
So I just started saying,
"I'm strong,
I'm prepared, this is easy."
From the moment I was in that
makeup chair crying
until show time I must have said
it 2,000 times out loud
and just walking around.
People thought I was crazy
but then I went to camera
blocking an hour after makeup
and I was like about to watch
the girl do my dance again
and I started kind of ...
I watched her video from the day
before
and I was like teach me
how you looked at the camera,
I was asking her
to do simple things
where I could actually
maybe move and get my ...
and then I started moving and I
was like I think I can do this.
And then I went out and did
the camera blocking
and Tom Bergeron,
the host, was watching was like
I thought you were injured
and I was like, "I did too."
It literally like, my mind ...
and I am because afterwards
it really hurt
and then I got ...
but I was able
to get through the pain
by just changing my mindset,
so I've
always been someone who's like,
oh you can meditate
your way out of pain,
a lot of our physical ailments,
our back pain, is just mental.
And people always go,
"No, I actually have a tear."
Well I did too
but it can be made worse,
an actual physical tear,
the pain can be made worse
by the way you
mentally think about it.
I know there's an injury there
but you got to change the way
you think about your pain
because you really
can overcome it.
It still hurt because there was
an injury there,
but when you're going through
a lot of stress
and you're down on yourself,
your brain needs a place
to go put that
and it finds the weakness
in your body,
which is wherever
you have a tear,
and it fucking beats
the shit out of it
until you release that stress
and so that's what ...
when I was able to
just like wrap my head around
you're strong,
you're prepared, you're ready.
It's easy.
It was crazy how it worked.
So I was able to dance.
I don't know where
I'm going with this.
No, but like your actual dance,
like when you were dancing,
did you have to think about it?
Yes, yes, yes.
Did the practice-
Yes, that was the problem,
because I didn't have practices
going in it was not like
second nature to me.
So like I wasn't ...
when I do The Tonight Show
I don't have to think about
what step is next
because yes it is a set
that I've constructed
and I'm not used to saying it
in this order,
but there's a cue card
in front of me
with the jokes listed
in case I forget.
Which I don't because
I've said this ...
I know how to do comedy.
But when you're doing a step
and you're like there's
another step to come.
The step is coming, you don't
get to make a pause and go,
"So what else am I talking
about?" Like there's ...
And it's loud in there
and it's like-
And if you don't know the step
you just don't know
and you do have someone
to lead you.
I wish I would have,
in retrospect,
I wish I would have thought
about dancing
as less of a me on my own
and Gleb kind of just guiding me
and
that I would have looked at it
as we were both one entity,
and I think that's really hard
for me as a comic who's been ...
you're so solitary up there.
I really thought
about my performance
and if you look at us,
I was dancing like by myself.
I wasn't dancing with him,
and I wish I would have thought
of it more as a unit,
which he tried to get through
to me so many times.
I really love dancing now.
I'm going
to do hip hop dance classes.
I know that I can learn steps.
I wish I would have stayed
in the competition
because I would have been
such a more fast learner.
It took me a month
to learn two dances
that were very similar
but then the third dance
I got so much quicker.
And then different styles
of dances,
I would have been so good
at the fox trot,
like where it's like
you just are ...
it's a slower dance.
I would have been so good at it.
I kind of got screwed
with my dance style up top,
I'm not a sexy salsa mama.
That's a little intimidating
coming into the box with.
That's how I always
thought of you.
Yeah.
That's how you're in my phone.
A little Latin fox.
But let me just tell you,
being eliminated
from a reality show
where it's like ...
and the next to go ...
like I was on that show,
I've been on that show before
because I've been
on Last Comic Standing twice
and been eliminated
where they go "moving on".
But I've never had my name said
as the eliminated.
You know what I mean?
Like it's usually and moving on,
and then your name
doesn't get said,
but I've never heard
who won't be ...
Do they pause for
like 20 minutes.
... and I knew,
I knew I was going.
I was staring down at the ground
and I knew
they were going to say
Nikki and Gleb. I just knew it.
I knew it ...
I had so much fun after I danced
because I just wanted
to have a good showing,
I wanted to have
a good talk time with the judges
and with Tom
and with Aaron Anders.
Yeah.
I wanted that all to go well
and when that was done
there was like a live
performance from this girl
whose song Mackenzie Ziegler,
she sang the song "Wonderful",
which we have to bump in and out
of break the rest of the show
with the song "Wonderful",
it just came out,
I'm obsessed with it.
She played it so many times
in rehearsals
that I learned the song and so
by the time she played it
for the first time on air,
Sia wrote the song
so it's amazing
and she's so good,
but I just like
danced by myself,
not by myself but we were all up
in the sky box
which is like the balcony
where all the dancers,
like the little bullpen,
and we were all up there
and I just like danced
during her performance
and was like this
is my last time
to like be on the show,
have fun, no cameras were on me,
and I just had the greatest time
at this
like McKenzie Ziegler concert
is how I treated it.
And then I went downstairs
and got eliminated.
And it felt, I just felt bad
because I wanted Gleb
to like have his showing on TV.
And he will,
like he'll go on and ...
I think Gleb will be fine.
He's going to be fine
but he really is so hot.
I met him yesterday.
So yesterday, so I flew to
New York immediately with Gleb
and then I go, you know what,
I'm going to spin this bitch.
Tomorrow I'm going on
Good Morning America,
who has that opportunity
that often.
This is still part of the show.
I'm going to kill it on
Good Morning America.
So I started writing jokes,
I started
strategizing with Gleb,
what are we going to talk about,
how are we going
to do the segment,
and I was like we have one more
performance, let's nail it.
And we went into
Good Morning America
with one hour of sleep,
we both got on the plane,
we watched I Feel Pretty
together, I fell asleep,
he loved it.
And he's like,
"You should do more acting."
Like he was trying to push me
into the thing
that I'm actually good at.
And we went on
Good Morning America,
we killed,
we had the best morning
because whenever Gleb
and I dance
it's always a struggle because
I'm so bad at it
and he gets frustrated.
And eventually we have fun
and we had good rehearsals,
but whenever
we would go do press
together, it was so much fun
because I got to shine
and show what I'm good at
and I got to teach him
a thing or two
because he wants to be better
about being on the mic
because English
is his second language
and he's like so hot
that he like
doesn't have to talk
for people to want to like him.
Kevin Hart's going to be in here
in a second.
Should we talk to him
about having resentments
because I'm sure he has some.
Yeah, for sure.
Oh look it he's getting
all ready to come in here.
I'm sure he still hates
a lot of people.
Yeah.
He's about to hate one more.
Don't tell him about my teeth.
Don't open with the teeth.
He's walking into studio now.
I ...
You have poodles?
... what'd you say?
You have poodles I can walk?
Kevin Hart.
Hello.
Hi, I'm Nikki, nice to meet you.
Good to meet you.
This is Ian and Andrew.
Hey Ian.
Hey, what's up man.
Let me shake your hand.
They're anticipating that
you'll see something in them
and produce something for them.
Yeah, yeah.
We were talking.
So you just want to really take
in their comedic talent.
No, this is great,
I'm looking at them right now.
Yeah, we get it.
Got anything, got it.
It's pretty ...
I started at The Laugh House.
Oh get outta here, Philadelphia?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Wow.
In Philly.
From Philadelphia?
Yeah.
Get outta here.
I'm from Wilmington, Delaware,
I drive up to Philly
every night.
Were you in the Mr. Rod Money
years or before then?
Mr. Rod.
Mr. Rod Money years, okay, good.
What does that mean?
That was one of the owners.
Oh, okay, all right.
Just testing to make sure
that he ain't lying.
He would have agreed
to anything you said, though.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
He was great.
You there when Derek Jeter
had it?
Yeah, yeah.
Number two, number two.
Yeah.
That's when he was great.
So, Kevin, you just came
into a conversation.
We were talking about
holding onto resentments.
People in the business early on
who tried to like
hold you back as a comedian.
I had a female comic
who just hated me
and spread lies about me
and rumors to hold me back.
And letting go
of those eventually
and I just talked myself
through it
and realized I'm still very mad
at this person.
I still wish her the worst.
As you kept talking
about it you realized that?
Yeah, I just realized.
Still festering.
You know I think
I'm still angry.
Yeah.
I don't think I've really
gotten past it.
What about you?
I'm a different breed.
I don't let much bother me.
It's hard to poke a hole
in my armor.
Yeah.
The reason why is because and
this is going to help you a lot,
it takes so much energy
to be negative.
You waste so much energy
holding a grudge
or figuring out ways
to maintain anger.
Because you got to create it
everyday or every time you see
that person you got
to conjure up more anger.
Like I was happy
but now let me be mad.
Yes.
And that energy is energy
that's being misused.
You know, so if you're true
to your craft,
you're true
to what you really do,
that's energy
that should be placed
and put into what you love.
If you choose not to do that,
then ultimately
you're cheating yourself.
So what I understood
at a young age,
and I got tons of rejection,
is that this is
what's supposed to happen.
I'm supposed to go through this
because ultimately
it's going to stop
and when it stops I'm supposed
to be okay and ready
for whatever opportunities
that are coming my way.
So instead of looking down
on the hate
or the negativity
or the nose, I embraced it.
I love that and I was voted off
Dancing With the Stars
two nights ago.
I was the first
contestant eliminated.
Big story around here, actually.
Huge. Sweeping the hallways,
this is Sirius XM.
Very, very huge story
as I was walking up they said
are you going to go on the air
just know
that she just got voted
off of Dancing With the Stars
so don't say nothing about that.
TMZ is in the hallway.
I wasn't ...
She'd have a lot of resentment
towards you.
That's the last thing
that I was going to say
but now that you bring it up,
you made it
an interesting topic.
Have you ever done anything
where you've agreed to it
and it's been something
that is ...
what's been
the scariest endeavor
you've taken
on professionally I guess.
Scariest endeavor?
Where you've had the most fear,
because I've never
danced before in my life
and I was like I'm about
to do something
I know I'm terrible at
on national television.
Have you ever ...
have you done
something like that
and how did you feel
on the other side of it?
Tons. There's tons.
Yeah.
Tons of things.
What's the most nervous
you've been,
or the most oh shit do I have
this moment in your career?
The most nervous?
It's going to sound crazy
but I'm probably the most
confident person in the world
so even when I've been
like holy cow,
there's now way, I still would
put on a face like I'm okay.
Like I did Fool's Gold, it was
a movie called Fool's Gold
that we had to film
in Australia.
And I lied. They were like,
"Are you okay with water?
Are you okay
to get in the water?"
Yes, like I'm actually
an excellent swimmer,
you know like this
is a true story.
Yeah.
Made it to the junior Olympics.
Yes.
Fucking excellent swimmer.
What was your stroke?
100 meter backstroke,
50 meter freestyle.
Nice.
My prime for a minute
went between my ages of like 12
and 15 was individual medley,
100 meter IM,
that's when I was like really,
really moving.
That was the real deal.
Swam like a 20,
20.2 50 meter freestyle.
Yards. 100 meter backstroke
I was probably like the 53,
54 range.
I was pretty good.
Real good.
This is all, you can go find
this information.
It's online.
I don't know what any
of that means
but that sounds really good.
Swim talk.
That's why my back
is so amazing.
But in the movie Fool's Gold,
I don't like the ocean.
Like unless I know like
where I am in the ocean
and what is in here
and I've heard it specifically,
I don't like the ocean.
Australia is
a different ballgame
when it comes to the ocean.
Because everything is there.
Everything is in Australia.
Great white sharks.
So, you know, they're like
are you okay
with getting in the ocean?
I was like yeah, yeah, yeah.
I just wanted the job.
Yeah.
Man this scene came up
and they're like, all right,
this is where you fall
in the water.
And I was like, "Huh?"
It was like these Irukandjis
that we kept hearing
about that was the most
deadliest jellyfish in the world
but we had heard rumors
that they were in the water.
Man, I said guys,
"I don't know."
And he was like, "What do
you mean you don't know?"
I was like,
"I just don't know,
I feel like
it's Irukandji in there."
They were like, "But you said
you were okay with the ocean."
I was like,
"Nah, I know I said that,
I definitely said that,
I definitely said."
He was like,
"Well, you gotta get in."
I was like, "I just want
to take to y'all about it,
I just don't ... I don't know
if we need this moment.
Do we really need ..."
I like tried to back track
and instantly I said,
"Okay, let's do it."
And I did about 13 of the worst
takes that you've ever seen.
Like they edited it
out of the movie it was so bad.
But I knew it.
Like as I'm doing it,
I was like oh this isn't
going to see the light of day,
I'm not even acting.
Yes.
This is complete fear.
I was supposed to be
the tough guy in this situation,
I'm not pulling it off at all.
That was the most uncomfortable
I've ever been,
but afterwards I was like it
is what it is, shoulder shrug.
Can't change it.
You can't change it.
You can't change it, they saw
it, all right.
I know, onto the next thing.
Gotta put that in your back
pocket.
Yeah, I mean,
but what is the ...
because getting voted off
a reality show,
being the first one voted off,
like I lost.
Gotta be somebody.
Like I lost the most.
It's gotta be somebody, right?
It's gotta be somebody.
What's the most rejection ...
what do you do when you feel
that level of rejection
which is like this
is the worst I could do
and it happened,
my biggest fear happened.
Which, I mean, what level.
I've experienced
every level of rejection.
Has it ever got you down
in a way
where you really
had to overcome it?
I'll give you two good ones.
Yeah.
Comic Strip, Lucien,
what's the last name, Holt?
Was it Holts or Hold?
I wasn't around for that,
but yeah.
Lucien ... legend
for picking talent.
Yeah.
He's the man that discovered
Eddie Murphy.
Lucien.
Kevin, you got an audition
at the Comic Strip.
Oh my god.
I been killing all around town.
I got into every comedy club.
Comic Strip was last.
They saved the best for last.
I'm going here
and I'm going to kill.
I go perform. Crowd goes crazy.
I can admit that my jokes back
then weren't
that ground breaking,
this wasn't cutting edge
material, but it was good.
It was good enough.
Yeah.
I'm a young comic, I'm 24.
Oh my god.
After you get off stage,
Lucien calls you
in the back room
and he sits you down
so you can find out if you pass.
Oh my, I've never been
more confident in my life.
Mm-hmm.
This is it. Lucien had a disease
and I remember his hands
and stuff were taped up.
I forgot what disease were,
but things would fall off.
Like limbs were falling off,
this isn't making a joke.
Leprosy?
Yes. Like this was real.
Right.
So bandages and stuff on but
it didn't matter,
like this guy's a legend.
Yeah.
In his most vulnerable state
of the last stages
of the disease
that he was dealing with,
this man told me,
he said,
"Comedy isn't for you."
I'm like what, huh?
I'm waiting for the ha-ha.
The punchline.
He said, "Maybe you should
pursue something else.
Maybe find a job,
but I don't see ..."
Swimming?
And so calm, I just don't see
you doing this long.
And I'm like, "What?
What are you talking ...
I don't understand."
And you just killed.
I just killed.
He's like, that's not,
I just don't see talent.
I'm not going to pass you.
And I sat there for a second
and I remember his hands
were like up in the air,
they had tape on them.
I could have said mean things,
I could have been like you ...
I could have said
a lot of stuff.
I stared at him for a minute
and he was like, "Thank you."
He kicked me out, like within
this condition, "thank you".
And I was like, "That's it?"
He was like, "Yes, that's it."
I get up, I walk out, my friend
Keith Robinson is outside,
Keith's like,
"What'd he say, Stupid?"
And I was like, "He told me
I should get a regular job.
He told me
that this isn't for me.
This is not a good job."
Like I should find
something else.
And Keith's honest reaction,
he was like, "Fuck him."
I was like, "Huh?"
"Fuck him. So what, Stupid,
let's get something to eat."
And Keith is,
this is my mentor,
this is like the guy who's been
giving me advice or whatever.
He didn't blink two eyes.
Yeah, he knew.
He wasn't devastated at all.
And he said let's get
something to eat
and it was like
nothing happened.
And instantly I processed that
moment as like what is that ...
am I going to stop
because of that information?
So what am I holding onto?
Right.
I immediately let it go
and we ate. And I was fine.
We went up at a spot
later that day
and I just went
to the comedy clubs
that accepted me
and worked those
and the Comic Strip
eventually found out
and they called me later on,
but I'd learned at the young age
of 23, 24 to say, "Fuck it."
So many people can't say,
"Fuck it."
So many people allow emotion
to overtake reality.
Fuck it is reality.
What just happened
30 seconds ago
I cannot change.
I don't have that power.
I don't know
how to go back in time.
You'll figure it out.
If anyone can figure out
the power to go back and change-
If I could I would, but I can't
you know wave my hands
and take that time back.
It happened.
That's why I address things
the way that I do.
That's why I have no problem
with admitting right from wrong.
I have no problem
with being real and authentic.
I'm a person.
Are you an apologizer?
Does that come easy to you?
An apologizer.
Like if you ...
If I'm wrong?
... if you're wrong.
They say never apologize
for a joke.
Are you good at being
able to be like,
even in interactions
with your kids or your wife
or just saying, "I'm sorry",
are you a good apologizer?
Because some people
struggle with that.
The older you get,
the more mature you get.
That should happen.
If it's not happening,
then I suggest you sit yourself
down and ask yourself why.
You're supposed
to get more mature.
Yeah.
I've fucked up a lot.
I've done a lot of wrong.
And me doing wrong,
I've realized
it's not just wrong it's stupid.
Okay, Kev,
how do you grow from stupid?
How do you grow?
You embrace what you did,
you own it,
because you made that bed
so you lay in it.
After you lay in it,
you get out that bed
and you say, you know what,
I don't want to make this bed
again for a long time.
Yes.
I don't want to make it again.
So I'm now aware. I'm conscious.
So when you say jokes
or apologize
for things you say on stage,
I don't say things that are
going to put me in a position
to have to apologize
because I'm aware.
So the lesson taught to myself,
be aware.
Don't be ignorant to what can
because you can always
prevent it before it happens.
So before you put yourself
in a position to apologize
there's a beat where you get
to make a decision,
do I want to throw this shit.
Yes.
Do I want to say this, do I want
to call them this name,
do I want to use this term
at this moment,
is there another route
that I can take
to get the same message across?
There always is.
Do you still make those
mistakes though?
And are you still willing
to make those mistakes?
Because I hear what
you're saying but I ...
when I mess up
it's sometimes hard
to acknowledge it and apologize
because then I feel like
an essentially flawed person,
but what you're saying
is like you can acknowledge that
and say no I'm going
to be better from now.
What's wrong with being flawed?
That's a great point.
So many people want
to live a perfect life
and I hate that, I'm coming off
like such a motivational speaker
but I'm just saying real shit.
So many people want
to live a perfect life
but you have no idea
what perfection is
unless you've
experienced imperfection.
Yeah.
You don't know what perfect
is unless
you've experienced imperfection.
In other words, embrace your
flaws, embrace your fuck ups,
they help make you ultimately
become the perfect person
you want to be.
Yup.
What individual do you believe
that's perfect?
Sometimes you look and you go,
they are perfect,
but it's all just ...
I don't really know what's
going on with them, you know?
You don't ...
what does it matter?
So if you're saying
I don't want to be flawed,
why, what's my question to you.
Because I don't want to hurt
other people,
I don't want
to be misinterpreted
and thought of as a bad person.
Like I think there's
a fundamental part
of a lot of us that just thinks
secretly I'm a bad person,
people are going to find out.
You know what I think?
What?
I think you think too much.
Yeah, I do do that.
I think you overthink a thought
before it becomes
a real thought.
You're thinking about
the thought behind a thought
that maybe
because I think
that this could.
Yeah.
It's a bunch of shit
that makes no sense.
Like you ...
It's a waste of time.
... you have no action yet.
You're thinking about
all this stuff
before an action
has even taken place.
Kevin Hart is here.
He has a new movie out,
Night School, which I haven't
had a chance to see yet.
Ian, you saw it.
I saw it, yeah.
You loved it.
Yeah.
Did you like it, Ian?
Yeah, I liked it a lot man.
It's coming out tonight.
There's some funny parts
in there, man.
Yeah.
Laugh out loud moments.
Yes.
I'm so excited about this movie.
Tiffany Haddish, Kevin Hart,
what more could you ask for?
And this is a movie
about second chances.
Mm-hmm (affirmative).
Is what I've heard.
Yeah, just what
we were talking about.
That's crazy that it's honestly
right on par
with this conversation.
Well tell me how so.
So, back to the point
of what we were discussing,
it's a movie about people
that feel like
because they didn't get it right
the first time
that there's no reason
to go back and try again
because they don't want
to be perceived
as a person that failed.
I don't want to look like
I failed,
I don't want to look stupid,
I don't want to look like
I couldn't do it
so I'm just going to not do it.
Yes.
Or trying to lie to make it
seem like you're not.
You're trying to create
a false presentation
of who you are based
on what you think
the opinions of others will be.
So in this movie
it basically shines a light
on those type of individuals
by looking through a lens
of a character
I play named Teddy Walker
who's putting on a façade
to a woman that
he's very much in love with
and making it seem like he's
in a position that he's not.
And when his charm and wit
and personality runs out
and he's in a situation where
his back's against the wall,
he's forced to get his
GED, he doesn't have a GED
but nobody knows.
He has to for the first time
apply himself
like he's never had
while trying to hide it
ultimately he comes across
other people like himself
and they band together
and realize
it's okay to be who we are.
Yeah.
And the piece of paper
that we look at that
can be sort of the diploma
has a much bigger meaning,
that piece of paper
makes you feel like hey
I'm making steps in the right
direction to succeed in life.
This makes me feel like I can.
That piece of paper,
at the older age that he was at,
put him in position
to feel like now can.
So this movie is
about doing things
that you think
you've already ...
it's too late to do them.
Yeah.
But putting on an effort
to do that and by doing that ...
by putting in the effort maybe
if you don't even get
the piece of paper.
It's still the effort.
Keep going back.
My guy does that ...
That's what I like.
... he doesn't get the piece
of paper right away.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. He's failing.
It's the fine beat
of how he's failing.
The GED is a tough test.
Oh no, 100%.
It's a tough test.
It's just saying there's
nothing wrong with failing.
There's nothing wrong with it.
Especially later in life, too.
Kevin Hart though,
you think Kevin Hart
and you go this guy
doesn't fail.
It's so nice to hear
that from you
because the reason you seem
like someone who doesn't fail
is because you've failed so much
and you have the attitude
of someone that says
there's nothing wrong with that.
Failure isn't failure.
It's not failure.
It grooms you for the wins.
Right now
I'm so determined to do so much
because I know what
the other side looks like.
Now I know I can't lose.
Because I have so much
information on how to lose.
Yes.
So if I didn't
take those losses,
then I don't know how to
properly take the wins.
And some people take the losses
and then they just stop.
Oh fuck that.
Yeah. I'm not doing it again.
There's an analogy my friend
Scooter,
Scooter Braun,
very, very good dude.
Scooter Braun told me something
one day and it stuck with me.
He said, "if I were to tell you
that right now I'm giving out
$5,000,000
to the first average individual
that can hit a home run
with a pitch
through by
a major league pitcher.
He said,
there's going to be a line
that probably is the length
of the entire city.
There's going to be a line.
Crazy people lined up.
The wait in that line
could be days
before you get
to get up to bat."
He said, "So many people
want to get in that line
and they're going to strike out
because this is
a major league pitcher.
And when they strike out
they have the opportunity
to go back
to the end of that line
and wait again if they want to,
or not, or they can go 'no way
I'm going to hit this pitch'."
Scooter said,
"The difference between me
and everybody else in the world,
I'm going to keep
getting back in that line
until they stop doing
whatever it is they're doing."
Whoa.
He said, "I'm going to get back
in that line and wait."
He said because that line's
going to get shorter and shorter
because nobody else
is going to want to wait.
When he said that,
I immediately said to myself,
I would be
getting back in the line
because that's the type
of person I am.
Mm-hmm (affirmative).
So with that analogy
it's a great moment for you
to ask yourself who are you,
do you wait in a line
for three days
to take three swings at a ball
that's being thrown
at 105 miles per hour,
or do you get up there
for the first time and go,
"Oh there's no way
I'm hitting that shit."
It could all be based upon
how many people quit
and then the last three people
they could get lobs
thrown at them.
Yeah.
Because they want to give
the money away.
You would never know because
you turned your back away
before you got to that point.
I'd be the person that pays
someone to wait in line for me.
And then just shows.
And then shows.
That's not a bad idea.
Not a bad idea.
Kevin Hart.
How many times are you
going to pay them?
I knew I'd come out of this
conversation
with you feeling better
about just everything.
You're so inspirational.
Thank you.
You're so incredible, I can't
wait to see Night School.
Thank you.
My mom I thought went
to night school for year,
I was like my mom
went to night school
because we'd always drop her
off at night school.
Turns out she got a DUI
and had to go get classes
and just told me that
she was going to night school.
I always go, "Mom, but you went
to night school right?"
She'd be like, "No I didn't."
And I go, "I remember
dropping you off there."
DUI.
Kevin Hart, thank you
so much for being here.
Thank you.
Thank you for all your wisdom
and, god,
I just love you so much.
See Night School,
it is in theaters everywhere.
Let's make this
a huge box office hit.
Tiffany Haddish and Kevin Hart.
I can't wait.
Night School is the movie,
Kevin Hart, thank you so much.
Thank you. Piece of good gym
dropping for you before I go.
Dancing With the Stars
was dope simply
because you got a platform
to show
that I'm okay
with not being comfortable.
Yes.
And now that you did that,
now you're back
to being comfortable.
Move on.
Yes.
It's over.
I love you Kevin.
Love you guys,
appreciate you all.
Thank you so much.
Take it easy.
All right, we'll see you guys
next week on the show,
thanks for hanging out
with us this week.
Squirt, squirt.